Meat Or Meatless?
Guess what!
One of my professors said humans are not meant to eat meat or drink cow milk.
So I drank soy milk today and avoided meat.
And you know what?
I already feel better!
I think I'm going to become a vegetarian!
Pull yourself together.
Being a vegetarian can be very good for you...
...but you must be knowledgeable about nutrition so you don't lack important vitamins and minerals.
Our body is very complex.
We need a lot of vitamins to support our system...
...and if you do not have variety, you might be asking for trouble.
And, I need you to settle down and think about this.
Meat is good for you too!
A benefit of meat is that it not only helps you develop a good immune system...
...but also helps you break down other nutrients in your digestive system.
Meat or meatless?
It is your choice...
...but some meat, such as chicken, once in a while will help you greatly by providing you with necessary protein.